Transcriptor: Alyssa Yanes
Revisor: Florencia Peirano
Hace tres años, mi ojo izquierdo
quedó completamente ciego.
Perdí la visión, producto de
un desprendimiento de retina.
Afortunadamente, gracias a una operación,
lentamente fui recuperando la visión.
Y lo primero que redescubrí
fue lo que tenía más cerca,
la naturaleza.
Vivo en un pequeño cerro
rodeado de un bosque precioso,
el bosque esclerófilo,
un bosque endémico de la zona central de
nuestro país.
Y empezar a ver nuevamente sus formas,
su contornos, sus colores,
las nervaduras de sus hojas
fue una experiencia extraordinaria.
Y así, creyendo que había recuperado la
visión,
llegó el 18 de octubre del año 2019,
y con él el estallido social chileno,
como se conoce a nuestro movimiento
social.
Ese día, miles de personas, millones de
personas...
mujeres, hombres, jóvenes, adultos
mayores, salieron a las calles a marchar
para pedir dignidad.
En ese momento, volví a sentir
el dolor de la ceguera,
pero una ceguera diferente.
Una ceguera de haber estado sin ver
la realidad de mi país
y sin ver la realidad de mis hermanos
y mis hermanas,
y eso me produjo un profundo dolor.
Ese dolor motivó a un grupo de amigos
a que emprendiéramos un viaje,
un viaje para ver, para escuchar y para
conocer a quienes nunca habíamos conocido.
Por 40 días y 40 noches, y gracias a la
generosidad de más de 400 personas,
pudimos escuchar en silencio,
conocer sus vidas,
las vidas de sus familias,
las de sus comunidades, sus territorios.
Pudimos conocer y ver sus dolores,
también sus fortalezas; experimentar
su solidaridad, su generosidad,
y también sus sueños.
Ha sido esa la experiencia más
transformadora, más bella, y más dolorosa
que he tenido en mi vida.
Y dolorosa por dos razones principales:
la primera es que muchos de los jóvenes
que salieron a marchar
durante el estallido social
para quitarnos,
no solo a mí sino que
a muchos chilenos y chilenas,
la venda de nuestros ojos,
perdieron sus ojos
y perdieron irremediablemente la visión.
A todos Uds. les queremos decir que
los llevamos en nuestro corazón,
y van a seguir viendo
a través de nuestros ojos.
Y el segundo gran dolor fue escuchar
en uno de nuestros primeros encuentros
a un joven en la comuna de independencia
que nos dice:
"llegaron tarde, ya no los necesitamos".
Escuchar esa frase
nos dolió profundamente,
nos estremeció y nos enmudeció.
Y volví en ese instante a recordar
a ese bosque esclerófilo
que para resistir la sequía,
lo que hace es que cada árbol
solo consume la cantidad de agua
necesaria para seguir viviendo,
y para con eso permitir que
el resto de los árboles y el bosque
siga existiendo.
No tengo dudas que nos necesitamos
y tampoco tengo dudas que nos necesitamos
de una manera diferente.
Necesitamos reencontrarnos, vernos,
escucharnos desde una honestidad total.
Desde una desnudez total.
Desde una generosidad total.
Necesitamos reencontrarnos y volver
a escucharnos, no desde lo que hacemos,
sino desde lo que somos.
Necesitamos encontrarnos guiados
solo por un amor radical.
Y a esta forma de reencontrarnos, nosotros
la hemos llamado la ética del encuentro,
y es una manera, una posibilidad de
reparar algo que hemos construido tan mal
y que tanto dolor ha generado,
que es nuestra infraestructura
de las relaciones.
El bosque esclerófilo es precioso,
el bosque esclerófilo genera vida,
genera agua fresca porque trabaja como
un ecosistema armonioso y colaborativo,
genera la posibilidad de que otros
organismos surjan,
que microorganismos aparezcan.
Ese bosque actúa colaborativamente
y cada árbol nunca se olvida
de que puede ser árbol
porque es bosque.
Y nosotros, los seres humanos,
hemos andado ensimismados en
nosotros mismos
olvidando que somos personas,
que podemos ser personas
porque somos sociedad.
Es el momento, nunca ha habido
un mejor momento
para poder reparar, reconstruir
ese tejido de relaciones
que tan mal hemos ido tejiendo,
se nos han ido tantos puntos de ese tejido
y hemos creado un abismo,
un abismo inmenso entre nosotros.
Nunca ha habido un mejor tiempo
para poder juntos construir
la pieza de tejido más hermosa
la pieza de tejido más hermosa de la cual
todos y todas nos sintamos parte.
Es el momento ahora de movilizarnos,
de salir de nuestras trincheras
despojados de las armaduras
de lo que creemos saber,
para ir descalzos al encuentro del otro,
poniendo en el centro de ese encuentro
la dignidad,
la dignidad de cada hombre,
de cada mujer,
de cada joven, de cada niño,
de cada niña,
en el centro.
Porque la dignidad de cada hombre, de cada
mujer, de cada joven, de cada niño
y de cada niña
es también nuestra propia dignidad.
Y desde ese encuentro
poder
reecontrarnos
en relaciones
como lo que hace la naturaleza
que se transformen en experiencias
extraordinarias.